- Le plus haut tribunal des
des pouvoirs de l'Agence de
protecnvnvnvnvironnementale,
l'EPA, qui édicte
la réglementation sure.e.e.e.e..
La Cour suprême est d'avis queer
et d'établir ces normes.
L'affaire remonte à 2015.
avait fait adopter des lois qui
réduisent le plafond d'émissions
produire les centrales
rbrbrbrbon.
La Cour suprême a invalidé
ces lois. Sous Donald Trump,
la règlementation était moins
co
en poste, l'EPA fixe des cibles
plus ambitieuses.
L'état de la Virginie-
de nombreuses centrales
au charbon poursuit l'agence
de protection environnementale.:
quels sont les pouvoirs réels
de l'agence? Dans une décision
rendue à 6 contre 3, le jugee e:
"Bien que l'imposition d'une
limite sur la production de gaz
carbonique soit sensée, il estbt
donné l'autorité à l'agence
de protection environnementale
d'adopter ses propresememememem"
Le gouverneur de la Virginie
Occidentale applaudit
de cette façon décision. " " " e
aiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiae
à la gaucicicicicale qui veut
faire ce qui lui plaît, affirme
la logique et le bon sens."L'ane
l'agence qualifie ce jugement
de catastrophique.ememememememes
de cette cour de protéger la
santé et la vie des Am, , , , ,e
d'armes à feu, d'avortement
et maintenanhahahahangement
climatiques."
Les trois juges de la dissension
considère c c c c c c c c c c cr
à l'agence de protection
environnementale de répondre
à l'enjeu le plus pressant
de
Ce porte-parole d'un organisme
environnemental juge qu'il sera
plus diffis s s s s s s s s s st
une réduction d'émissions
de gaz carbonique.
"Nous devrons peut-être faire
des compromis, explique-t-il.
Ce qui compte en ce moment c
d'agir tout de suite parce que
l'agence de protection
le plus important pour lutter
contre les changemen
climatiques, nous n'avons pas
Le président Joe Biden parle,
lui aussi, d'un jugement
cette décision ne tient pas
compte de la jurisprudence.
Il y a 15 ans, la Cour suprême
de protection environnementale
pouvait et devait contrôle
les émissions de gaz à effet
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Wasn.n.n.